- [narrator] This UCSD-TV Program is
presented by University of California
Television. Like what you learn? Visit our
website or follow us on Facebook and
Twitter to keep up with the latest
programs.
- We are the paradoxical ape, bipedal,
naked, large-brained, long the master of
fire, tools, and language, but still
trying to understand ourselves. Aware
that death is inevitable, yet filled with
optimism. We grow up slowly. We hand down
knowledge. We empathize and deceive. We
shape the future from our shared
understanding of the past. CARTA brings
together experts from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are and how
we got here, an exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
- [Elizabeth Hadly] I particularly
appreciate being invited because
I'm not a paleoanthropologist, and
I don't really study climate specifically.
Instead what I'm going to do is give you
the perspective of the other
animals that occupy the earth,
these small animals,
large animals, and I'm gonna definitely
delve us into the future and ask some
tough questions about our population. So I
titled my talk somewhat provocatively
about tipping points, and tipping points
are ...they're situations of a state where
you have a non-linear kind of system, and
when you move beyond some particular point
in that non-linear system, you can't go
back to where you started. I'm gonna
advocate that we're poised on the edge of
tipping point for planet earth. So when
some threshold is crossed and the question
is are we about ready to cross it or have
we already, the system is gonna move into
a new state, and the example I put up here
is an egg about ready to go off the edge.
Ice melting in the Arctic might be another
one to think about. So mass extinction is,
I've been asked before whether or not the
earth has shown tipping points, we know
they happen in tons, they happen in small
ecosystems. But mass extinctions in fact
can happen on the planetary scale. We
already saw this mass extinction graphic.
They're labeled there. The old divisions.
Silurian, the late Devonian, the Permo
Triassic where we lost 95% of all the
species on the planet. The Triassic
Jurassic and the KT where we
lost dinosaurs and a lot of marine
reptiles. The point is that these are mass
extinctions, and you'll see in every case,
there's a drop, a drop in diversity. This
is generic marine diversity. So this is a
marine record, not a terrestrial one. But
the point is, is that when it recovers,
and it takes between five and 10 million
years for life to recover after these mass
extinctions, life is completely different.
We've lost these organisms that founded
the diversity on the planet prior to the
extinction, and they don't come back. So
it reassembles. It is in fact a new state.
So the Earth is warming rapidly. You've
seen many versions of this, but I'm
providing here a little bit of a
perspective about ...from our perspective.
So we're here on this graphic, all of
those different color squiggles showed
difference in areas depending on what
models are used by IPCC. We will be here.
Now you've heard a lot about the evolution
of humans, modern humans. By the time we
get to that point in 2050, we will have
planetary, global planetary temperatures
warmer than our species has ever
experienced on its time on Earth. And if
we happen to make it to 2100 and to
temperatures somewhat above four degrees,
Earth has not been as hot as that
projected temperature in 14 million years.
Now the perspective is, and this is one
I'm giving you, mammal species don't live
that long. We don't have mammal species on
the planet that are 14 million years old.
So the memory of this climate in the
genomes of this species is gone. World
population is still growing. Now there
will be 9 billion people on the planet by
2045. So 2045 here, there will be nine
billion people, and if we don't, if we
continue at ...these are current fertility
rates shown in that upper blue, current
fertility rates, you can imagine, I mean
15 million people on the planet.
Unbelievable. In fact, fertility rates are
slowing, but not fast enough. We would
have to, instead of replacing ourselves a
male and a female with two children, we
would have to go down to just point five
children per person to follow the lower
blue curve. So human population growth is
the elephant in the room. It is
tremendously terrifying. So even though
the late Quaternary transition from the
Pleistocene, the cold era Pleistocene to
the warmer, more wetter Holocene, is not
exactly analogous, and in fact very
different in many ways to the kinds of
climate we're experiencing today. In fact
there are two similar features. One, we
are warming the environment as we move
from the Pleistocene to the Holocene, and
we're also expanding as humans. We're
colonizing the globe. So those two
features are in fact something we share
with what's happening today. So you heard
a little bit about these dramatic warming
and cooling events. Here's the bowling
arrow rod and then followed by an abrupt
younger dry as a cooling event that saw
the extinction, for example, of Irish elk
in Ireland as that environment cooled
rapidly. And then we end up into what's
called the Holocene are really about the
last 10,000 or so years of relatively
constant temperatures. However, we
expanded in this latter part of the
Quaternary. We left Africa around 200,000
years ago. We colonized Europe and Asia.
We colonized Australia, somewhere between
40 and 60,000 years ago. And then we made
it to the Americas last, somewhere between
13 and 35,000 years ago. Now with our
colonization of these isolated areas, we
caused extinctions. This is a photo. This
beautiful image is the menagerie of
animals that used to roam in North
America, and are now no longer here. There
are gopathirs, giant ground slogs,
glyptodons. There's the giant bison.
Camels, which basically evolved in North
America, left, colonized Asia, colonized
South America, and went extinct to North
America. And then horses, which again have
millions of years of history in North
America, and went extinct, only to be
recolonized by Spanish explorers
historically. About half the world large
animals, animals larger than 44 kilograms
or about 100 pounds, went extinct at this
time. Incidentally, humans are about that
size. So it's not just our impact that
caused change in animal distributions and
abundance. In fact, there are some small
mammals, like this bog lemming that went
extinct at this Pleistocene-Holocene
transition. So we know that ice covered
much of Canada, and there was no place for
these bog lemmings to live. Every one of
those black dots you see in North America
were occupied by bog lemmings during the
Pleistocene. They're no longer found
really in the lower 48. In fact, what they
are, they're occupying this orange range
up here. They are really an ardic
sacamordic [sp] species. So they responded
as you'd expect a species that likes a
relatively cold environment. As the ice
left, they tracked that environment
northwards. But not all species responded
that way. These are two images of two
species that are found in a cave called
Samwel Cave that I excavated several years
ago in Northern California shown by the
black dot there. These two species didn't
really respond north. In fact, they
contracted their ranges to higher
elevation but also much weather
environment that's currently found in
Samwel Cave today, which is located on the
shores of Lake Shasta. So these animals,
the mountain beaver, it's not confined to
mountains, nor is it a beaver. It is the
remnant, the last species of what was a
very large group of species in the family
Aplodontia, which is a very ancient North
American family of rodents, and it is the
only species left in the family today. It
cannot ...it's very primitive, and it
cannot concentrate its urine. And so it
has to be by running fresh water all day,
all the time. And so you find them
confined into very dense, old growth
Douglas fir forests along the coasts in
the Pacific northwest, a very ancient
lineage that is threatened by warming
temperatures and dry conditions. The other
animal you see is the white footed vole.
Very little is known about this animal,
except the fact that it is somewhat
arboreal, and it's found in deciduous
trees and probably up in this old growth
Doug fir forests. Again this animal
contracted with the Doug fir forests and
warm weather condition, not so much higher
up in elevation. Animals today are moving
northward, just like they did in the
Pleistocene. This is a range map of the
current distribution in 2013, the black
line is the current distribution of the
armadillo. The armadillo is related to
that glyptodon, that giant thing I showed
you in the previous slide. It's a South
American animal, and it is expanding. It
made it across the Rio Grande in 1850, and
it's expanding northward. It's limited by
winter temperatures, so if there are 24
freeze days or more, this animal can't
survive. Its young can't survive. And
what's happening is as our North American
climates are warming, this animal is
progressively colonizing further and
further north. And so what you see not the
excess, but every other symbol on this are
instances where armadillos have advanced
beyond their 2013 static range. Be
interesting to know where there are after
this winter. However, the thing about this
that I wanna point out is not just that
animals respond the way you predict they
would based on what we know from fossils,
but the other thing is this particular
animal, the armadillo, is the only mammal
we know about in the world that carries
leprosy. And so this is an example of this
unexpected synergistic things that can in
fact impact humans in ways we don't
anticipate. Actually they got leprosy from
us. Leprosy evolved in Asia, most likely
India, and they contracted leprosy from
us, probably somewhere around Louisiana,
but this animal can transmit leprosy to
humans as well. So similarly to what I
explained to you about the mountain beaver
and the white footed vole, animals will
find their proper environments. And so
it's not just that they moved further
north, they ...as warming conditions
prevail and as drying conditions prevail,
they'll also move up an elevation. So many
of you might have heard about the pikas.
This is one of the Asian species. There
are in fact 28 Asian species of pikas.
They're related to rabbits and hares.
They're just most wonderful thing to work
with. They have this enormously
interesting physiology. They have a
resting body temperature of about 104
degrees, and they live really high in the
Himalayas. They live above 15,000 feet.
Now the problem with ...so we've been
studying these particular animals all
along the Himalayan front in India and
Nepal, and it turns out that only some of
these species can tolerate the hypoxic
conditions that are characteristic of that
high elevation. So these particular
animals, and in fact they've shown to be
moving up much more rapidly than American
pikas, of which have moved up around a 150
meters. In the Himalayas, they have moved
up at least a thousand meters, and they're
pinched, right, from above because of
those hypoxic conditions, and from below
from warming, and also human alteration of
their environment. Now another kind of
unexpected example, and again to
demonstrate just what ecosystems mean in
terms of how species are connected. This
is the map you see on the left is a map of
the distribution of, on present, the
whitebark pine distribution in North
America. White bark pine is a high
elevation pine. It's the last conifer that
until you get to tree lines, which the
thing you often see in krummholz in the
Rocky Mountains. It's a five-needle pine,
and it has this really, really nice
calorically rich nuts in the cone.
If we just look at climate models for the
distribution of the whitebark pine and you
can go to 2030, 2016, 2090, you can see by
2090, there's barely any whitebark pine
left in the lower 48. Now that projection
was made before we saw what happened with
the mountain pine beetle. For those of you
that have traveled anywhere in the Rocky
Mountains, you know that in the last
decade, conifer forests, all the way up to
tree line, have been decimated. In the
Yellow Stone region, in some of these
areas, white bark pine are down 80%. This
is a photo from one of the high elevation
areas that I worked in in Yellow Stone,
and you can see a lot of standing dead
trees. Now, okay, so that's because the
beetles are allowed to survive over the
winter. It's not killed off. It's a native
beetle. The climate is definitely,
definitely implicated in expansion of this
beetle. It's now goes all the way up to
tree line. It's not killed off, and it
probably reproduces several times per
year, instead of having to recolonize
every year. But why is that? Why do I have
a picture of a grizzly bear? It turns out
that the number of whitebark pine cones in
a tree is directly correlated with over
winter survival of adult bears and their
cubs. And it's indirectly correlated with
problem bears the following summer. So
when there's not a lot, in some cases they
may eat 40 to 50% of their fat is a result
of eating these middens of
cones. They're mostly ...again, another
player in this sort of Clark nut crackers
and the red squirrels here, but these
grizzly bears need this to pack on the
fat. And what happens is they come out of
hibernation earlier, and they start
getting into trouble looking for food in
human dwellings. So again, an
unanticipated and kind of surprising but
very major impact from climate change. The
other thing that happens in ...these are
data I'm not showing you the actual data,
but during the Pleistocene-Holocene
transition, one of these ...there were
lots of different small mammals in the
Samwel Cave site in Northern California I
talked about, but the animal that just
took over that site is the deer mouse,
Peromyscus maniculatus. And in fact this
animal has dominated the entire Holocene
assemblage. So the community structure of
small mammals change just ...and this is
not due to human hunting. This is due to
the fact there are many more disturbed
environments in the Holocene. This animal
has very high intrinsic rates of growth.
They don't care what the environment is.
They don't mind if it's just been burned.
They don't mind if it's the edge of a
field or if it's an old growth forest.
They like disturbance. This animal is the
most commonly trapped small mammal in
North America. So if you lay a trap out
there anywhere outside of human
habitation, you're likely to catch this
guy. It also tends to carry a lot of
diseases. So this is a witty species, and
it thrives with human environments. And
the specialist species are the ones that
take a nosedive. Now I'm sure there are
some of you that are gardeners here, and
they don't consider this pocket gopher as
a particularly favorable friend in their
garden, but in fact these guys took a hit
at the end of the Pleistocene. This is the
pocket gopher. It has fur-lined cheek
pouches, and it stores its seeds and digs.
In fact this is a specialist species. It
is so energy expense ...energetically
expensive to live underground. It takes
between 360 and 3400 times the energy to
do this and to move the same distance
above ground. This is by any account a
very specialist species. So they declined.
Humans are directly causing the extinction
of animals. We've lost, or threatened to
lose almost a quarter of our species. I
just read an article that said we're
...about a third of our bird species in
Europe are threatened. Most of these are
from hunting. We're about ready to see the
loss of elephants in the next decade or
two. One out of every 12 elephants was
killed in just the last three years. This
is a crisis. 51% of humans, of the
terrestrial land has been co-opted for
human use. The only places left on this
map that aren't shown in purple are
deserts and tropical forests. Those are
the least easily farmed land on the
planet, but they're also in some ways,
especially the tropical forests, some of
the most important. Everywhere else, we
have made a mark. We have an extinction
debt and we will lose a lot of
biodiversity in the near future. I get
asked a lot, can speciation rescue
biodiversity? Absolutely not. Species take
between two and five million years, this
is mammal species, to evolve, so we can
cause them to disappear in a decade or
two, but it takes millions of years to
accumulate the diversity we might have
lost. So how do we avoid this tipping
point? This planetary tipping point? We
increase energy conversion obviously. We
stall habitat loss. We increase global
cooperation. This has got to be done
globally, and we stabilize population
growth. And finally, how do you stabilize
population growth? I get asked what is the
most ... In my opinion, the single most
important thing for us to do is to educate
women globally. And the reason is because
as education goes up, fertility rate goes
down. The more girls that are in school,
secondary school, the number of years is
really important, the more fertility rates
go down. And interestingly, GDP and
poverty rates also go up. Human innovation
is remarkable. We can see the origin of
the universe. I can't believe we can't see
the origin of the universe, and we can see
ourselves in our beautiful planet from
space. Why can't we avoid the next tipping
point? Thank you.
- [Naomi Oreskes] I'm often told that my
talks are very depressing. So I'm pleased
to follow Liz Hadly, who's talk was
even more depressing than mine.
If we didn't already have enough to worry
about, now we have to worry about
armadillos carrying leprosy.
So I was given an assignment for this
meeting, and it was very upbeat question.
Will we survive the future? So I'm happy
to say that I actually have a positive
answer to that question. The answer is
yes. I do believe we will survive. As Liz
just showed us, we're a much greater
threat to other species than other species
are to us. And short of a meteorite impact
hitting ours I think that the odds that
humans as a species will survive are
probably very great at least for the
foreseeable future. It seems to me the
more relevant question though is how will
we survive, and particularly in what
condition? Anthropogenic climate
disruption and its companion threat of
ocean acidification threatens to reverse
the developmental gains of the past 50
years, decreasing the quality of life and
wealthy nations and pushing still more of
the world's poor as well as other species
to the edge of survival. The President of
the World Bank, Jim Yong Kim, has recently
noted that climate change is a fundamental
threat to development, one that threatens
to reverse 50 years of progress. So what
will a future of unmitigated climate
change look like? Not just physically, but
socially, economically, and politically?
This was the question that Erik Conway and
I set out to answer in our book that also
has a very optimistic title, "The Collapse
of Western Civilization." The book takes
place in the year 2393, when a historian
looks back on our present and asks the
question, "How was it that they knew so
much about what was happening to them, had
so much good scientific information, and
yet did so little to prevent it?" The year
is 2393, the occasion is the commemoration
of the Great Collapse of 2093. I wanted to
read to you from the book, but time
doesn't permit that, so I'll just
summarize the argument and hope you'll go
and buy the book, which only costs 6.95,
and it's Kindle edition.
So first our historian recounts what
happened in the Great Collapse. It begins
with the collapse of the west end Arctic
ice sheet, and this physical collapse then
ramifies into social dislocation and the
collapse of economic and political
systems. Then she tries to answer why
question, "Why did people let this
happen?" And she argues that the grip of
free market ideologies, combined with
scientists' failure to communicate what
was truly at stake, created a disabling
paralysis. So my question today is, how do
we avoid that future? The question of what
kind of future we will have is really the
question of whether we are capable of
addressing the problems that are before
our eyes. And this, of course, is not a
new question. Indeed, I would argue it's
the Malthusian question. In 1798 as most
of you know, Thomas Malthus asked the
question, "Can the Enlightenment project
work?" By that he meant, can we reasonably
expect to improve the condition of
mankind? And his short answer was no. And
for this reason, Malthus is often
considered an anti-Enlightenment
philosopher. He rejected it's impossible
and even misguided the Enlightenment
aspiration to achieve the perfectability
of man and of society. He even doubted the
possibility of long-term and sustained
improvement. Now most of us also know why
Malthus came to this pessimistic
conclusion. It was what he called the
positive checks. Positive in the sense of
absolutely positively certain. And those
with the checks of famine and disease and
the misery and mortality that ensued from
them. Now most of us also know that,
happily, Malthus was wrong, and it's
generally taken to be received wisdom that
the main reason he was wrong was because
he failed to appreciate the empowering
effects of technological innovation. The
19th and 20th century saw technology
enabling a number of key developments that
helped to stave off the Malthusian
disaster that he imagined. The most
important, of course, was increased food
production, but also arguably, equally
important, better public health through
sanitation and vaccination, which led in
turn to the greater survival of children.
And the survival of children, along with
the education of women and the development
of technologies, available technologies of
population control, allowed many of the
nations of the world to bring their
fertility rates down without the misery or
vice that Malthus feared.
Because of this success, because of how
much technology played a role in the
development of the western world in the
last 250 to 300 years, technological
success has become a foundational tenant
in many of our beliefs, particularly those
of us living in wealthy industrialized
technologically endowed nations, where we
have benefited the most from these
technological successes. Indeed, our
belief in technology is so foundational
that we can name several philosophies that
express this belief. So, for example,
technophilia, the love of technology.
Cornucopianism, the belief in the
continued productivity of technological
innovation. Technofidiesm or faith in
technology. And more recently something
I've been calling disruptivism, a belief
in the power of disruptive technologies.
In fact these philosophies are so powerful
that some of them even have their own
bibles. So some of you are familiar with
the Bible of Cornucopianism, the book, The
Resourceful Earth. Now one of the things I
find most interesting in ...about faith in
technology is that it cuts across party
and ideological lines. In fact I would
argue it's one of the few things in
western culture that does. So the
cornucopians are mostly conservatives and
neoliberals. They have confidence in human
ingenuity and the capacity of the
marketplace to do its magic. The
technofidiest tend to be traditional
Republicans, Democrats,
and what I call paleoliberals.
As opposed to neoliberals.
I guess we have to have mesoliberals,
too, but I haven't figured
out who they are yet. Technofidiest
tend to believe in government investment
in technological R&D. And then there's the
disruptivists, who I haven't quite figured
out what they believe in, but they talked
about the need for disruptive technologies
but without specifying how those
technologies come to exist. But all agree
on the crucial role of technology. What
they disagree about is how we get it. So
liberals tend to focus on education and
research particularly in great research
universities and institutions like this
one and UCSD across the street.
Conservatives stress free market economics
and entrepreneurship, and these
disruptivists don't say.
But here's the rub, and actually there are
several rubs. I'm a historian. There's
never only one answer. The first rub is
what I'm calling the cargo cult mentality,
and we have anthropologists in the
audience, so I hope they'll appreciate
what I mean by this. When you listen to
the advocates of technological solutions
to climate change, no matter of the left
or right or in between, one is struck by
the similarity to anthropological
descriptions of the cargo cult. By that I
mean we are waiting for the goods to
arrive, but we have no coherent plan how
to get them. The cornucopians, for the
cornucopians I would ask, but what if the
market doesn't do its magic? To the
technofidiests I would ask, but what if
basic research doesn't translate into
usable technologies? And to the
disruptivitists, what if the climate
disruption arrives before the
technological one? The second rub, much of
this discussion ignores what we have
learned or should have learned from
experience. It ignores what we know from
the history of technology about how
transformative technologies became normal
parts of our lives. Now I live with
historians, and historians don't like big
generalizations. There are no laws of
history, and we tend to focus on the
specifics of individual developments and
cases and cultures because we know they're
all different, but there is a
generalization I think is broadly true
about technology in the 20th century. And
that is that none of the transformative
technologies of the 20th century were
produced either by market-based mechanisms
alone or entirely by government R&D
either. Rather, nearly all the transform
of technologies of the 20th century
involved government private sector
partnerships, and here's just a short
list. I couldn't fit them all on a slide,
but just some examples. Rural
electrification, the development of
telephone and telegraph, aviation and air
traffic control, nuclear power, the
Internet, digital computing, space
technologies, pollution control
technologies, all formed by
government-private sector partnerships. In
fact, the only two exceptions I could come
up with, and being at this institute I
have to mention the polio vaccine
and the contraceptive pill,
also developed largely here in
southern California. These
were private-private partnerships, but
we're one half of the partnership was
philanthropic rather than private sector
entrepreneurial. Electricity is a very
well-studied case in point. We know a lot
about the history of the development of
electricity. We know that entrepreneurship
brought electricity to most Americans in
major cities, but it took governmental
initiative to bring it to rural citizens,
and that's true in other countries as
well. In fact, most other countries have
rural electricity before the United States
did because their governments were less
reluctant to get involved, and because
they viewed electricity as a common good
rather than as a commodity. The third
problem is what I'm calling the problem of
persistence forecasting, and by that I
mean assuming that the future will be like
the past. Technology has led the way in
many radical changes in the way we live,
but will it be up to the challenge of
anthropogenic climate change? The Zen
masters have said that technology makes
major contributions
to the minor needs of men.
Now I think that might be a bit strong,
having a warm, safely lit house and clean
water and good food would seem to be more
than minor needs. But still, in a world of
laptops and iPhones, one may well wonder
are we getting the technologies we want,
or the technologies we need? It's now a
truism that Malthus was wrong, but the
fact is that billions of people on Earth
today do still lack adequate food and
water, and they do suffer misery for that
lack. And in many parts of the world,
childhood mortality remains very high.
Life has improved dramatically for those
of us in the upper four billion is I think
Roman [sp] often calls it, but it remains
highly unimproved for at least 2 billion
of our fellow citizens. And in public
health, it's well-documented that medical
breakthroughs of the past decades have
mainly addressed the diseases and even the
discomforts of the wealthy to the neglect
of many of the most devastating diseases
of the poor. So why have we made so much
progress on telephones and contact lenses
technology and cosmetic surgery, and such
relatively modest progress on solar cell
efficiency and energy storage? Well, I
think one part of the answer is clear,
market response to market signals. And
without a price on carbon, there's
insufficient demand for energy efficiency
and storage. Governments will respond to
political signals and those have so far
been largely lacking as well. And of
course this also explains why we haven't
solved the diseases of the poor. And the
fourth issue is the issue of inequality
and inequity. Today, technological
development has not resolved problems of
inequality, and in some cases has, in
fact, exacerbated them.
So perhaps Malthus was right after all,
and technology just bought us extra time.
So will we survive the future? Again, I
still think the answer is yes. But how we
survive hangs in the balance, and it will
depend in no small part on how quickly we
can develop the technologies to transform
our energy systems. And to do that, we
can't just sit around chattering about
disruptive technologies or letting the
market do its magic, while meanwhile the
fossil fuel industry continues to explore
for and develop still more reserves of
fossil fuels, including the Arctic, one of
the few places on Liz's maps that is
not filled with people. And of course, we
continue to use those fuels. We have to
get past wishful thinking and
technofidiesm to apply what we know from
experience it is likely to take to solve
these problems. And that brings me to the
thorny issue of politics. People don't
like to talk about politics. It's awkward
and divisive. In fact, we've had a whole
set of wonderful speakers here today, but
no one has spoken about the evolution of
political systems or the evolution of
governance. But without talking about
political systems and governments, I don't
see how we can solve the problems that we
face. Now many people have seen an analogy
between our problem of relinquishing
dependency on fossil fuels and the 19th
century problem of relinquishing
dependency on slave labor. Interestingly,
some of the people who invoked the need
for disruptive technology to solve climate
change are the same people who invoked
this analogy with the disruption of ending
slavery. But slavery was not ended because
of disruptive technologies that eliminated
the need for slaves. It was ended by a
disruptive politics that included acts of
terrorism, of illegal sheltering of
escaped slaves, and finally culminated in
a tragic bloody military conflict. Now few
of us are prepared to break the law to
stop disruptive climate change, and I'm
not advocating that we necessarily should,
and I've certainly heard many of our
colleagues criticize climate scientist
James Hansen for "crossing a line,"
becoming an advocate because
he has been arrested protesting the
Keystone XL Pipeline. I do not know
whether what Hansen is doing is right or
wrong, or whether it will make a
difference or not, and of course, no one
does. But as a historian, I will say this,
most of us in the climate science arena
have been focused on science and
technology, and to a lesser extent, on the
business side of business as usual. But
what may matter most, what may be most
urgent, and what may actually determine
the question of how we survive, is whether
we can create and sustain a disruptive
politics. Politics makes nearly all
scientists very uncomfortable. We don't
want what we do to be politicized and we
are afraid of being seen as political. But
it seems to me very unlikely that we can
solve climate change with politics as
usual. And it seems to me also very
unlikely that we can solve climate change
without ...with our scientific thinking as
usual either. And so maybe the time has
come to think about that.
Thank you very much.
- [Ramanathan] We heard from Jeff
Severinghaus about the greenhouse
effect of carbon dioxide in Venus,
and that brought me fine memories
when 45 years ago, I got started in this
field, like taking the quantum mechanics
of the carbon dioxide molecule and trying
to figure out how it maintains the climate
of Venus and Mars. So how did I go from
quantum mechanics to talk about the topic
which is totally foreign to me, in pursuit
of the common good. So I have to walk you
through how my science led me into the
villages of India and Kenya, and finally
found myself face-to-face with Pope
Francis last year, and that's what gave me
this idea of the pursuit of common good.
So let me start with the 30-second lesson
on climate and climate change. The
fundamental energy source for the planet
is sunlight considered solar
energy. Not all of that is absorbed by the
planet. The intervening clouds and ice
sheets surface bounces some of these back.
Somewhat 70% is absorbed by the planet
that heats the planet and it gives off
this energy, the infrared wavelengths. We
call it heat radiation, infrared
radiation. But not all of that can escape
the space. The intervening atmosphere,
particularly water vapor in carbon dioxide
acts like a blanket and traps this heat.
In fact the blanket is a good analogue, if
not a metaphor that the blanket keeps you
warm on a cold winter night, not because
it gives off any heat, it traps your body
heat. That's exactly how these gases trap
the planet's infrared heat, which is what
we call by greenhouse effect. Nature gave
us a thick blanket, and later I'll tell
you how thick that blanket is, so without
that, the planet would be so frozen beyond
anything you see in the ice ages that Jeff
showed us. So now what we've been doing is
adding to the blanket, making the blanket
thicker. So the first of this, we heard
about the carbon dioxide, and that was
worked out more than years ago by Svante
Arrhenius, the famous chemist. He did some
of the most definitive calculations in
1896. I know this paper very well because
the Swedish Academy at the 100th
anniversary invited me to write a detailed
critique of this. So for maybe 80 years,
after the publication of this paper, we
thought carbon dioxide was the only
molecule causing the greenhouse effect. In
fact many talks where they focus on the
CO2. After I finished graduate school, I
stumbled on this totally shocking and
surprising discovery even from myself that
we were losing other components,
particular the chlorofloroucarbons, CFCs,
and my work showed bringing ...taking
again starting from the quantum mechanics
of the CFC molecule. Addition of one
molecule of CFC has the same green house
effect as adding to 10 to 15,000 molecules
of carbon dioxide. This isn't, mind you,
purely synthetic gas used as refrigerants
and propellants, but the CFCs were also
involved in damaging the ozone layer. So
the Montreal Protocol in 1980s phased out,
banned the use of chemicals after the
discovery of the Antarctic ozone hole.
Just in the last five years, my work was
recognized, and The Economist called the
Montreal Protocol as the best climate
mitigation strategy because my work had
shown if we had not to buy any CFCs, the
CFC alone would have cost half a degree
warming so far. Okay? So now let me go to
the real gorilla on the table, which is
carbon dioxide. The theory is being
attacked, so the key thing is to remember
any theories judged by its predictions. So
in 1980, I teamed up with the famous
metereologist Roland Madden. We took the
observed climate fluctuations, so-called
noise. Until when will we detect the
signal of carbon dioxide warming. So we
predicted, if the theories, Arrhenius'
theory was right, we should see the
warming by year 2000. As you have seen,
it's after the 1990 to 2000 [inaudible
00:42:08] shown the shade were the warming
grows above the background noise. In fact,
thousand scientists said finally we are
seeing the human-induced warming. So there
a forecast came out to be okay. So for the
last 30, 35 years, I used varieties of
instruments. The one I'm showing on the
left hand side is the satellite which I
helped design that with three other
scientists at NASA. We were looking at the
regulation of the heat flow in and out of
the planet by the atmosphere. More
recently, we developed this unmanned
aircraft to look at how that heating from
man-made pollutants is really warming the
planet. So let me walk you through. What
we did was using this to track down each
of the prediction by models and theories
and see, are they coming too true? So the
first thing we went after is what's called
the water vapor feedback. Remember I think
Jeff showed several talk about the warmer
atmosphere has more moisture, but water
vapor is the most powerful greenhouse gas.
So we determined the greenhouse directly
simply by ...we have estimated the
infra-radiation coming from the ocean,
basically given by the plancks black
body law. Then we were measuring the heat
escaping to the top of the atmosphere and
difference the two. Look at the thickness
of this blanket. What you see here in the
tropics is where the blanket is at its
thickest. Our unit for measuring the
thickness what's the energy trapped.
So why is so much greenhouse
effect happening in the tropics? It's warm
and humid water vapor greenhouse effect,
but we are not satisfied with that. We
wanted to see as the planet warms,
how the water vapor increased.
So on the right hand side you
see, I'm not gonna go through step by
step, every year, the planet does a
spectacular experiment. It's the entire
planet for the average, it's hottest
during August and coldest during February.
Remember, August is winter in the southern
hemisphere. So when the temperature
increases, we found with the satellite,
the greenhouse effect increased exactly as
predicted by models. And then you ask why
did that increase? That's the last bottom
panel, it's because the water vapor
increased as the planet temperature
increased. So why is the water vapor
increasing? It's basic thermodynamics. The
weight per pressure of moisture above a
body of water increases exponentially with
temperature. So here it is. Arrhenius was
the first to suggest it. The next was,
another theory which was done by Russian
climatologist so-called CI Salvedo.
Charlie Kennel already
showed that. This took me 30 years, to
start from the launch of the satellite to
come to this. It was still one of my
graduate student's thesis work.
So as the arctic sea ice are treated, what
the climatologist said is, "You know, ice
absorbs absorb only 50% of the sunlight.
It bounces everything back. That's why it
white." When you melt the ice away, you
get the sudden tipping point. You see the
dark ocean. And the document of that
exactly how much energy, as that energy
increased, although it's a tiny part of
the planet, Arctic, was so large that it
was equal to one-fourth of the greenhouse
effect of CO2 increased. Okay? Again, this
was suggested by the magnitude of the
feedback is much larger than what the
models were using. The last one I wanna
mention to you, one of the key things we
are after this is the warmer planet going
to be more cloudy? Why is that an
important question? Clouds are one of the
most powerful regulators of sunlight. The
clouds are white because it's reflecting
50 to 70%. In our planet, both in the
northern polar regions, southern polar
region, is massive extra tropical cloud
system. Remember, that's what you see when
you fly across in the Pacific-Atlantic,
thick, white. They are the refrigerants
for the planet. What we are finding is
...now think of them as two white
umbrellas. They are shrinking, letting in
more sunlight in the tropical ocean.
Again, an amplification. So when we put
all of these together, remember, I
forecast in 1980 boldened by the success
of that, we made two forecasts seven years
ago that we have already dumped enough
gases to keep the planet by two and half
degrees. We have only seen about one-third
of it. The other thing which is what made
me go out to the pursuit of the common
good, I said we are gonna hit these two
degrees, not when ...people are saying
hundred years from now. Around the corner,
30 to 40 years from now. Okay? So the
so-called two degrees is facing us
already. So how do we slow down warming?
Of course, most of the studies talk about
cutting down CO2, which I agree with.
We came with the number to reduce the
long-term warming. You got to stabilize
the CO2 below 440 bpm. CO2 is already at
400. So to limit to 440, we can't emit
more than thousand billion tons. That
looks large, but every year they are
emitting 40 billion tons.
So we have only 25 years left.
Okay? But that's not gonna help the
near-term warming because CO2 is like a
super tanker. Its lifetime is centuries of
thousand years. It's not gonna respond
quick. So remember, my work on the CFCs,
that's put us hc halocarbon. That's a
family of chemicals. And after that work
in '75, we came with numerous other
pollutants. Ozone, it's called smog.
Methane, we heard about it. The other is
black carbon. It is such the dark stuff
that comes from diesel. It's not a
greenhouse gas. It's a particulate of
sunlight. Much of my work with the UAVs
must attract that. But we have
technologies to cut them down, and their
lifetime is few weeks to a decade. If you
eliminate black carbon from diesel, their
warming effect is gone two weeks from now.
So we said if you cut these pollutants
with existing technologies, we can cut
down the rate of warming in the next 30
years by nearly 50%. So you need a
two-prong strategy. So now let's look at
who is gonna do which. By the way, this
idea of the CCAC, the short-lived climate
pollutants, I wrote a paper of this for
our policy makers, that the political
scientist at UCSD, that was read by
Hillary Clinton, and she formed the
coalition three years ago. Now there are
40 nations are working to cut down the
short-lived pollutants. So now let's look
at the human side of the problem. For
reasons I'm not gonna get into, I spent
...took my sabbatical and spent with my
wife living in villages in India for three
months. We also do work in Kenya. Every
week or so, the life in the village was so
oppressive. I would escape to the nearest
city for the cold glass of beer.
I have a movie I can show if there is
time. That's when I discovered, my God,
there are two worlds in this planet. The
first is inhabited by the top one billion,
with obviously seemingly unlimited access
to fossil fuels. The other one is
inhabited by the bottom three billion,
lack of access to the fossil fuels, even
for cooking. They still burn firewood and
coal lump. I was having my meals in this
woman's house, in the foot of Himalayas.
So the top one billion, consumed 50% of
the energy, are responsible for something
that 50 to 70% of the greenhouse gas
emissions. So where population is a
problem, as Dr. Hadley said, the other big
gorilla is unsustainable consumption by a
small part of the world's population.
Okay? Particularly climate change. So in
terms of cutting CO2, the buzz word is
decarbonization. So that takes about, it's
been estimated, about a trillion dollars
per year. That's about thousand dollars
per person for the top 1 billion. And our
fossil fuel subsidies about 450 billion.
So you take it out. It's basically a $500
problem we are looking at. And then
the second thing is, the worst
consequences of climate change is going to
be experienced by the bottom three
billion. This woman represents about 600
million women around the world, who are on
subsistence farming one or two to five
acres. A drought like what hit California
extending for three, four years would wipe
them out. They would become homeless,
called the slums in cities, et cetera, et
cetera. So the question is we have to give
them energy access. And that has also been
cost a lot. It's about 250 billion. So if
we divide it amongst the top one billion,
it's $250 problem. So the question we have
to ask is, why should I? I'm living here.
I'm of course part of the top 1 billion.
I'm one of those on the top of the top one
billion if you bring on my travels. So why
should I give $250 to this woman sitting
in Himalayas? If I don't do that, she
climbs on the fossil fuel ladder, her
consumption of fossil fuel go by 30%,
another 12, 13 billion. So purely selfish
reasons, we wanna [inaudible 00:52:35]
energy access, but we know if we throw
250 billion, it's not gonna reach them.
All right? So we started a project called
Surya, where we developed improved cook
stoves to cut down the emission,
my daughter developed
cellphone technologies to measure these
emissions. My instruments were all way too
expensive, but this cook stove is about
$70 a person. That's about five weeks of a
paycheck. Okay? So we said, she's cutting
down climate by cutting down the black
carbon emissions, some CO2 emissions.
She's saving about five tons a year. So if
I give them minimum carbon credit to her,
which is about $15, she get to pay stove
paid off, and she'll be making next two,
three years. But how do you know she's
gonna use it, right? That's the biggest
problem is compliance. So I went to my
daughter again, asked her to
do something useful.
She's a wireless technology genius.
So she came up with a simple
temperature sensor,
which hits us. As soon as she starts the
stove, the data comes to her lab, but
she's at Los Angeles. She sends it
to my lab. We convert the carbon
credits. UCSD created the first climate
mitigation fund, and we demonstrated it in
5000 homes. In fact this work was started
first by donation from Qualcomm, Charlie
Kennel, and a billionaire in San Francisco
got it started. So next week, this
methodology has been accepted by United
Nations. I'll be there next ...in the
summit. They're going to release it as one
way, the point energy access. So let me
go. So I'm now taking my quantum mechanics
to villages. So why did I need the pope?
Clearly, after we ...particularly we heard
from the last speaker and the previous
speaker, I deserve by the way, I'm never
going to follow Naomi Oreskes.
I was so mesmerized what she was saying I
forgot what I was gonna say.
So we teamed up. I belong to the Pope's
Academy of Science with the economist,
Nobel Laureate and biology, physics,
chemistry. In fact, Charlie and Naomi
attended that summit, and we discussed to
see this whole issue of sustainability.
And at the end of it, we were asked to
brief to the pope, and I've been in this
academy for last ...every time we meet
pope, like Pope John Paul and Pope
Benedict, it's always in the most ornate
room in the Vatican. This pope met us in
the parking lot right here.
That's why he's called people's
pope. So we briefed. What was remarkable
about this group, at the end of it, three
[inaudible 00:53:51] talks, we didn't talk
about technology. We didn't talk about
this. What we said was the main way to
solve this problem is to change our
attitude towards nature and towards each
other. And remember, by leaving three
billion behind, they're gonna suffer the
consequences of our fossil consumption,
and then from the previous speaker we
heard we're going to generations of yet
unborn suffering our [inaudible 00:56:05]
consumption. So it's a moral issue. So
what we are saying is that religious
leaders should take hold of this. And two
weeks ago, Pope Francis, because of this
previous meeting, assembled religious
leaders from Islam, Hindu, Jewish, all the
religious leaders represented, and they
all signed a declaration. And anyway, so
let me just come to the last point. I
joined this infamous group Planetary
Boundaries Group. So we published this
year this planetary boundary that has,
that is a safe ecosystem, that's an inner
circle. And then you exceed the outer
circle. You go to the danger zone. And so
there were eight components we identify. I
was the only climate scientist there. And
climate change, and then the atmospheric
aerosol loading is there. Two of the
components we already exceeded the
boundaries. Dr. Hadly's talk beautifully
showed that species extinction. It turns
out our extinction rate is 10 to 100 times
larger than when we compared the
extinction rates before humans really
started colonizing the planet. The other
major is nitrogen. Fertilizers. We have an
oxic zones in the ocean
because pollutants, effluence
from the ocean. So climate change, there
are denialists because of political and
economic reasons, but our chairman also
said we are also a denialist. It is coded
into our genes. So no matter how, if we
don't do much about it, I wanna conclude
mine with my prediction that you see that
the red zone, the climate was still in the
yellow zone, we would exceed that by 2050
two degrees. So the anthropocene, which is
coined by my good friend Paul Crutzen,
will reach adolescence by 2050. I'm
thinking there the teenage is the most
dangerous age in the human being's
evolution.
Right? So we'll reach two degree world.
When I predict when we reach two degrees,
the changes would be so huge, just
physically and thermodynamically, the
water vapor alone would be 15% more,
fueling the storms, fueling droughts,
fueling floods. So we would change our
attitude towards nature. We will
decarbonize the economy. But I am saying
it's a $450 problem amongst the top one
billion. Safe to assume all of us here
belong to that prestigious club. And then
we need to provide clean energy for the
bottom three billion. Okay?
Thank you very much.